BUKOLA AYOCELE: So far, we've
covered three strategies
for scaling your
serverless apps.
Lucky for Critter Junction, we
have three more up our sleeves.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To review, Critter
Junction's new wallet app
lets users send and
receive virtual currency.
They're using Cloud Functions
to provide response to queries
around wallet amounts.
But they hit their database
back end rate limit,
so they couldn't experience
the scale that serverless
provides, and wondered what
other tips they were missing.
So my team came in and helped
them set up instant scaling
limits on Cloud Functions,
Cloud Tasks, to limit
the rate of work done,
and stateful storage
to defer results from
long running operations.
Let's explore three more tips.
#4, use Redis to
rate limit requests.
Sometimes you need
to perform rate
limiting in the context
of the http request.
For example, you might
want to protect your system
from abusive users with
per user rate limits,
like 100 wallet
queries per minute,
to control the flow of requests
your serverless workloads.
Or you might need
a back pressure
to the caller of your
serverless workload,
like if your wallet
transactions called
the API that check for fraud,
which has a limit of 100
requests per second.
You need a defense measure
to ensure all your serverless
functions respect
that limit and prevent
the API from excessive use.
And Redis is great
for doing this.
It gives you a very low
latency key value datastore,
plus basic data
structures and operations
that make it one of
the preferred backing
source for rate limiting.
Google Cloud offers a
fully managed Redis service
called Cloud Memory Store.
If you want to learn how to use
Redis to limit cost function
invocations, check
out the link below.
Tip 5.
Use Cloud Pub/Sub up to
process the work in batches.
When you're dealing with a
large number of messages,
you might not want to
process every message.
A common pattern is
to wait until messages
have accumulated.
Cloud Functions integrate with
Cloud Pub/Sub in messaging
and ingestion middleware.
Instead of invoking a Cloud
Function for every message,
serverless workloads can
use Pub/Sub as a place
to accumulate batches of work,
since the service will store
messages for up to seven days.
Then you can use Cloud Scheduler
in managed cron job service
to process these
items on schedule.
You can even trigger
the batch processes
based on the number and age
of accumulated messages.
This will help you
control the flow,
and your functions can
better handle increases
in trigger requests.
And finally, our last tip.
Use Cloud Run for
heavily I/O work.
One of the most expensive
components of infrastructure
is compute cycle.
When your serverless
workload is just
waiting for a remote API call
or waiting for files to read,
these are billable moments.
Cloud Run, a managed
platform for running
stateless containers,
lets you specify
how many concurrent
requests, it can handle.
This can mean big
increases in efficiency
for I/O bound workloads.
For example, if
the work being done
spends most of its time
waiting for replies
from slow remote
API calls, Cloud Run
supports up to 80
concurrent requests
on the same instance, which
shares the same CPU allocation.
What you want to do, is one,
tune your service performance
for the maximum
stable concurrency.
Two, set your expected
level of concurrency
in any code level configuration
and deploy your service.
Three, set Cloud Run
concurrency equal to or less
than any code level
configuration.
Four, then use low
testing tools that
support a configurable
concurrency,
and make sure that your
service remains stable.
Critter Junction now
has six strategies
for their serverless scaling
in their back pocket.
They can use rate limiting,
set instance scaling limits,
and products like Cloud Run,
Cloud Task, Cloud Scheduler
and Cloud Pub/Sub
to help manage load
on their serverless instance.
Even highly scalable
systems should have limits
on consumption to reduce the
chance of cascading failures
and maximize throughput.
For more details on these tips
and an awesome decision tree,
check out the link below.
That's a wrap for a
"Season of Scale."
Stay tuned for more strategies
for scaling on Google Cloud.
And remember, always
be architecting.